los contagios de kobe 19 siguen
disparados en eeuu el país registró 1
record en 24 horas el viernes y el virus
se propaga con velocidad a lo ancho del
país
mientras en el oeste oregón y nuevo
mexico anunciaron las restricciones más
duras desde que inició la última ola de
contagios en el este nueva york se
prepara para un posible cierre de
escuelas luego de decretar el bloqueo
nocturno de bares y restaurantes para
los comerciantes es un nuevo golpe a
messina afip obviamente no estoy
contento parece que fuera un presagio de
futuras restricciones pero un
confinamiento no entra en los planes del
presidente de donald trump el mandatario
se adjudicó a méritos por el avance de
las vacunas y depositó sus esperanzas en
ellas para vencer a la pandemia
melián ser de 6 millones de dosis
saldrán pronto están listas esperando la
aprobación final en abril la vacuna
estará disponible para toda la población
en general
violation también en norteamérica ciudad
de méxico anunció un recorte de horarios
en los establecimientos como cines
museos y teatros ante el alza de las
hospitalizaciones una situación que
contrasta con las aperturas en el sur
chile permitirá a turistas extranjeros
desde el 23 de noviembre sin exigirles
en cuarentena pero si una prueba pcr
negativa anualmente a chile entran cerca
de 4 millones de turistas extranjeros
hasta el momento durante este año han
entrado un millón 100 esperamos que con
esta reactivación puedan podamos subir
en unos 300.000 adicionales por su parte
argentina rehabilitó la actividad
presencial de las artes escénicas con
restricciones sanitarias y aforo
limitado a la mitad una medida que
permitirá volver a encender las luces
apagadas en los siete meses de
cuarentena